bonjour les ondes et fontaine merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france grande mobilisation
aujourd'hui un an jour pour jour après
le début du confinement où en est la
situation des étudiants et pourquoi cet
appel à manifester aujourd'hui et bien
bonjour à toutes et tous la situation
des étudiants est dramatique
un an après l annonce du premier
confinement on l'a vu en décembre
dernier un étudiant sur six en
décrochage scolaire ce nombre a
probablement augmenter dans les semaines
et mois qui ont passé une précarité
étudiante qui en hausse qui était déjà
présente avant le continent et
d'ailleurs j'avais déjà pu en discuter
sur votre plateau mais qui s'est accrue
avec la pandémie et face à cela un
gouvernement et une ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur fregat vidal
qui est complètement déconnecté des
réalités
et qui dit que tout va bien que jean
castex a annoncé dimanche dernier sur la
chaîne twitch de samuel etienne qu' il y
avait fait le maximum pour lutter contre
la précarité étudiante
or nous ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
que c'est d'une part pas le cas et que
les images et les réalités le montre
notamment vu des centaines voire des
milliers d'étudiants qui tous les jours
vont devant les organismes dissolution
alimentaire pour subvenir à leurs
besoins primaires et donc la situation
est loin d'être des traîtres
le gouvernement est loin d'être laid n'a
pas fait du tout son maximum éduquons
demande non seulement la réouverture des
universités pour les étudiants mais
également un plan d'urgence pour lutter
contre la précarité étudiante qui passe
entre autres par la revalorisation des
bourses dans un premier temps mais
surtout la création d'un revenu
étudiants et sa l'ensemble des
organisations de jeunesse c'est inédite
dans l'histoire ce sont tout renier pour
demander un revenu étudiants pour
l'ensemble des étudiants financer au
dessus du seuil de pauvreté
ah c'est cette mobilisation du
centenaire j'insiste elle n'est pas
uniquement sur les étudiants et concerne
toute la jeunesse également les jeunes
en emploi parce qu'aujourd'hui sont
confrontés à un chômage à un gros un
chômage qui augmente 22 % des jeunes au
chômage au dernier trimestre 2001 la
précarité qui est qui est partagé par
toute la jeunesse également pour les
lycéens qui subissent encore une fois la
sélection entraînée aspect alors que le
contexte inédit devrait plutôt invité
aux assauts
un plan de rattrapage pour permettre à
tous les étudiants et à tous les lycéens
de rattraper le retard qui a été
accumulée depuis plus d'un an mais alors
une manifestation pour la jeunesse mais
pour revenir aux étudiants le
gouvernement avait pris des mesures pour
les aider on peut parler dur par un euro
par exemple de l'aide de 150 euros
mensuels accordés aux étudiants
boursiers ou encore d'un chèque si
c'était pas suffisant c'est pas
suffisant selon vous non c'est pas
suffisant et c'est arrivé tardivement en
fait c'est arrivé suite à la
mobilisation que nous avions initiée
justement le 20 janvier dernier où le
gouvernant du coup à généraliser suite à
cette mobile en mai mobilisation massive
des étudiants
le repas un euro et voilà mais emmanuel
macron avait annoncé quelques mois
auparavant en effet des différentes
aides pour les étudiants qui à l'arrivée
c'est z on les attend toujours
elles ne sont toujours pas arrivés d'une
part et voilà et le repas un euro je ne
sais pas si vous avez vu passer mais ils
se sont en même temps que le prix a
diminué la quantité également diminué et
les repas un euro aujourd'hui nous
soumet pas suffisant pour avoir un repas
convenable dans la plupart des
restaurants universitaires que les les
portions sont ont été diminués pour se
re parano dans un grand nombre de
restaurants universitaires on voit la
multiplication des témoignages ou en
effet on se retrouve avec une 200
grammes de nourriture sans viande etc et
en effet sont allégées depuis le repas
un euro c'est inadmissible et ce n'est
pas tant à cause du crous que du fait
que l'état n'investit pas dans le crous
pour permettre à chacun justement de
retrait mine de se restaurer de
dignement avec une nourriture de qualité
avec un repas surtout qui permettent de
manger convenablement le chef de l'état
y l'a dit on souvent il l'a répété se
dit préoccupé justement par par vous les
jeunes qui avaient voté d'ailleurs
particulièrement pour emmanuel macron il
multiplie ses apparitions sur les
réseaux sociaux comme le premier
ministre jean castex vous l'avez dit sur
twitter
est ce que justement le fait
d'apparaître sur ces plateformes pour
vous c'est audible
c'est audible en effet il ya plus de
jeunes qui les écoutent certes en
revanche qu'on déplore aujourd'hui c'est
que le gouvernement préfère soigner sa
communication auprès des jeunes plutôt
que d'agir concrètement pour les jeunes
et twitch les différents influenceurs
qui ont été sollicités par le
gouvernement et cetera ne suffiront pas
à masquer la réalité que rencontre
l'ensemble des jeunes d'aujourd'hui
la précarité des jeunes ne cesse
d'augmenter le taux de chômage des
jeunes ne cesse d'augmenter le nombre
d'étudiants vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté ne cesse d'augmenter
et cette réalité c'est la réalité
concrète que vivent les jeunes mais ça
ne sera pas juste une multiplication des
chaînes de passage sur la chaîne switch
ou de gabriella talent sûr sur twitch
également ou sur instagram qui
permettront de lutter efficacement
contre la précarité des jeunes et à un
moment nous les jeunes nous disons qu'il
en a assez assez justement de ces
discours larmoyant de ces techniques de
communication nous voulons des actes une
politique forte pour lutter contre la
précarité des jeunes et pour un plan de
rattrapage pour l'ensemble de la
jeunesse
il ya une crainte d'un reconfirmant et
l'éventuelle notamment en ile-de-france
et les honneurs en ce moment il ya une
crainte
oui en partie comme toute la population
nous allons pas être confinée et ce qui
se comprend
en revanche comme toute la population si
ces mesures sont nécessaires eh bien
nous nous plierons bien évidemment à ce
confinement
pour l'instant ce qu'on constate c'est
que ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour ça
fait quelques mois du studio manque on
est sorti du premier confinement pour
autant une partie de la population reste
confinée c'est celle des étudiants
aujourd'hui même si les maliens de la
pro a annoncé une réouverture très
partielle des universités on constate
que ce n'est pas le cas que tous les
étudiants ne sont pas encore retourné au
banc l'université et donc on a déjà une
population réalité qui est confinée
depuis un moment c'est celle des
étudiants et nous ce qu'on dit c'est
qu'il faut des confiner les étudiants
pour l'instant si demain on a des
mesures de confinement strict qui permet
de lutter efficacement contre la
propagation du virus
nous nous y plierons pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas donc nous demandons à
ce que les universités bien sûr puisque
vous venir très ouvrir convenablement en
respectant bien évidemment les gestes
barrière merci à léon des fontaines
d'avoir livré votre témoignage ce matin
dans la matinale verte et france jeu